Russia is at it again that's the claim
and a new article in US magazine the
Atlantic
it says the Kremlin has set its sights
firmly on meddling and the upcoming
midterm elections with a Russia's
objective being to weaken America now
the whole article goes on to explain
Russia's alleged three-step plan to
break American democracy first unleash
the Russian hackers second by corrupt US
politicians and third support those who
think favorably of Putin it's not just
our Russian state that has come under
suspicion the Atlantic also claims that
this channel RT helps to undermine
democracy by inviting on guests who
questioned the mainstream narratives
they named Brandon Straka as an example
he's the founder of a movement
encouraging Democrats to walk away from
their party though the Atlantic fails to
address other channels that also have
him as a guest well I I myself was a
lifelong liberal democratic voter I
would say kind of a Democrat by default
because I'm a gay man and I think that
the expectation for a lot of minority
groups is that we are supposed to vote
Democrat and that we are supposed to be
liberals Brandes Drake has spent years
as a liberal he now says he's concerned
by what the left has become well before
the election I was already starting to
feel uncomfortable with where we were
headed in terms of identity politics and
PC culture the political commentator
line all told us what he thinks is
behind anti-russia articles like that of
the Atlantic nobody ever calls these
people to task they're paid for by
volume or how many likes did you get how
many clicks hey that was a great article
factually incorrect factually a baseless
and also the mentality this feeding
frenzy of this this monster this MA this
monster that you must feed constantly
with us know Russia no NATO
no bad guy no bogeyman so there's many
reasons why the boogie man the straw man
the specter the evil image of Russia
must be maintained because it fills
because somebody talked about what time
the power of nightmares it was wonderful
BBC documentary and and you need
something to fear you need something and
historically in this post you know Cold
War a red-baiting this Russo phobic
hysteria fees into this as well and
there's an audience for it
you